hi I'm you da Vinci wall bender
University is a communication system
Department and I will present wait why
saying with Mathematica
hello I knew the Banshee mall for Mendel
University
I would like to describe and break up
development for ray tracing of the
little magnetic waves in Mathematica
it's out no not so rational to do it but
I will describe what happens anyway so
we have a scenario about the city part
of the city this is a real city but I
cannot put it is because of the
application behind and in this pink
areas meeting using it's a flying
elements above the city from behind we
want to break what is the position of
each computer in high accuracy and you
know in a passive mode of receiving the
rather world so actually if you look the
pink area is the region of interest
right now for the experiment we know
where are the transmitters and other
models you need only to the layout of
the buildings you need the high trust or
some parameters but actually like a
purple one and the old one is really the
printers so we started with the model
that we developed the colleague of mine
and I this model is stochastic models
let's say in an average city with such a
distribution of buildings and parameters
like what is the line density of the
buildings what is the distance between
the transmitter and the receiver is a
profile of the height of the building
and the height of the a transmitting
antenna and receive antenna lots of
assumptions but in let's say in
conventional cellular applications like
mobile telephones and the
above the roofs on some tower of 30
meters it's quite accurate and we have
made experiment with some cities in
Europe and it was okay a another
advantage of this model that we can have
even to calculate the Doppler shift is
it is received by the silver antenna and
actually what we were asked to do is to
check this model with it's a mobile
receiving antenna several three of them
because you have to do triangulation and
to try to locate where are the
transmitters okay so we had a lot of
information we did it with Mathematica
this model and we do huge amount of
information but actually the comparison
was not successful because the type of
the measurement this is a stochastic
model so you need repetitive experiments
and we had only one experiment with lots
of data and we couldn't verify it we
actually can do what we were asked to do
so I decided to check the model later
with another verification concepts like
white question because my question is
highly numerical you cannot have
insights like a theoretical model but
it's accurate for a specific scenario
okay it's done
again so since we have so much work done
with Mathematica I decided to do it
already with Mathematica so what is
weight wasting okay weight rising is a
method just you mimic is a transmitter
like a bunch of ways and propagate how
the heat walls heat boundaries hit
concrete some of the energy dissipates
and actually this technique is used in
graphics nowadays even in cellular
telephones their GPUs or they used
to wonder the screen especially in games
this picnic for it racing but we are not
doing propagation or white racing of
light because behave differently because
it's not colors we have the same
frequency and it doesn't change color
and actually behind the scene we want to
buildings lots of parameters like how
many metal inside the building how many
windows
where are the windows where are the
corners and lots of parameters are very
important let's say for electromagnetics
but it's not important or optics so we
needed some advanced tool to do this so
the torii behind the way tracing we
explained the question did say only is
the set of muscle equations
usually if the frequency is high enough
so the wavelength is small enough
according to comparing to the buildings
and this is accurate enough so let's say
we walk with 30 centimeters in below
wavelengths and the buildings are at
least several meters most of the
building were 10 or 15 meters height so
it should be accurate enough now I was
faced with a problem I want very process
a ray tracing I want it to be combined
with Mathematica and I want to all as
less as possible because I don't have
enough time so I skip I scanned the
market what you can do so there were
several tools on CPU ok like over here
it's very famous blender yeah for many
applications that can do it but they are
all waitressing of light and if you want
electromagnetics hard within the
framework to modify it for electro
magnetics there are several tools also
for GPU to do it faster Nvidia propose
optics and very simple reason of optics
is called optic pie it works only with
triangles but you have to feed the GPU
with a set of triangles and set off rays
and they let it walk it should walk very
fast but I don't know C++ and who
activates a such thing I need to learn
say C++ so I decided not to do it
MD is a long term project also it calls
em the weather but in ways it's very
similar to optics and it's open source
if anybody is interested in working with
AMD if you'll so you can use it and
actually for scientific research it's
not enough to avoid it rather just give
you the paths of the ways but there is
low notes behind this
so I decided okay well I will do it with
Mathematica so every to a balance to
make why Mathematica so lots of import
and export so I got the building from
somebody else so I have to read the
building's another permit this time it
was a file of MATLAB but a team at caño
to import this type of files you reach
libraries for region and geometry to
describe the buildings you have all the
mathematical functionality to analyze
the result we have graphical tools just
will display the results and if I want
to compare it vertical model of course I
have authority model I have the results
I just have to do waitressing and
compare and I know mathematical words so
I thought it would be a nice experience
to do it if make it short it was a nice
program so I smiled and it was for me so
it was embarrassing because I don't fine
but
I didn't plan anyway so if we look at
right away sir are very simple tasks
applications
it was input many PD polygons usually
most of the time it's triangles keep it
simple and fast you have a set of ways
like the region or flashlight for optics
or length and you have the position of
the wheel where you want to measure the
result for electrodynamics wave just an
antenna what the proximity of the
antenna considered as they received a
signal and the task is to compute as
fast as fast as possible as the passes
of the wise and each time it reflects
from the wall you have to calculate the
angle next time and take it like second
car away and usually everybody does too
we decided to do more okay and if it
happens at it it's like the corner of a
building the edge of the building there
are other models that know much not like
what happens in optics how to calculate
the dispersion of the waves the ones
opponent okay
so compute as fast as possible actually
each wait ways to do it as fast as
possible need to do two things fast okay
and also fast is much better than fast
because it has lots of computation to do
first of all if write hits a triangle
you have to find this point because in
usual scenarios are many triangles so we
have to do it fast and you have to
compute the direction of the reflected
ray so a an efficient way to do it is
know
to try to intercept the way against all
the polygons against all the triangles
now many ways of subdividing let's say
the buildings or the way is according to
stylus but they are the partitioning
object petitioning and you actually try
to find what is the building where is a
collection of triangles that you have to
do the actual computation in step one
and this is an important step this is
not implemented yet in Mathematica but I
did it beside any without it oh let's
say our started so instead of several
years ago and the two students developed
something similar to in building not in
human environment inside buildings it
took them on a GPU just to develop the
application about eight months they were
very proficient provenance in GPU it was
a walk of about seven to eight months
just to get application I don't have
enough time to do it for so long time so
he took me it took me about two weeks to
finish everything so I started with okay
how can I describe ready so there is an
object in automatically half line it's
like a laxative widget and then it can
be infinite line and so you can describe
it like half line between two points or
half line between the origin point and
the direction of propagation this is
what I use okay this is very good now
how can you find where it intersect is a
building so there is another fantastic
function that is called regional
intersection so you have to describe the
building is a region or is a graphical
object and then do the computation this
function is very fascinating but it's
very very slow so just to see what
happens
the way God expects a position of
transmitters and usually you have two
options
all you mimic the way is transmitted but
then you have to do lots of rays because
you don't know if it's actually fine get
its way to the receiver or do the
opposite which is using what if it is
not you do interest rates transmit the
way is from the receiver because you
know they're there and you collect only
the way that get near the transmitter
which is more efficient so we can see
what happens here in some scenarios so
first experiment just use what
Mathematica offers don't try to do any
optimization so just for an example just
for this demo so you see it took one way
and one building now just for this case
it's represented as couvade we can see
that actually the way intersect is
building so you should get an answer for
this but how fast it is so here is an
answer do it 10,000 times which is small
number of repetitive intersection for
such an application to 20 seconds very
very slow it should be fraction of a
second so we I decided to do version 2
okay
the main problem when I investigated
what what is the cause like we did 1
million raise at least so took about 25
hours with the strong computer xenon it
calls 1 Mathematica in power lots of ROM
and actually took about 25 hours just to
get the computation run okay so present
- it was okay let's move to triangles a
Y triangle because then I can change
there's a function using intersection
intersection with another function that
doesn't have to compute what is the
object it knows that a triangle
what is another object it knows it's way
so we just can't take so so many options
out there
I took one functions it is considered
very efficient and modify to
mathematical this is all the code very
simple what we see it's a polygon
polygon of three points so it's right
angle with half line and you can use
this there are several condition to stop
the computation in advance if you know
that some condition is not met so no
intersections there is a symbolic answer
empty region in three dimensions and
finally if something is correct so you
have to give this and the parameter T
that is computed actually answer this is
intersection point okay
so just another performance measure now
I have to work with triangles so I took
what this pair the objects are described
building and triangulated so by a
boundary discrete graphics is very good
you can do also discretize the graphics
but say it considers the volume I want
envelop of the building so I have four
walls and the ceiling because some rays
can bounce from the building and
actually what happens that I cut the
computation time in half but say okay
next step what can we do these functions
that I used is quite simple so we can
compile because all I need is just
vertices but there is another problem
okay I got almost a factor of two
performance but if if you look at the
code Mathematica is a symbolic function
so the same function can return
answers number converting the symbol is
not an erect or whatever you like it
like an object and in compiled version
you cannot do it have to be the same
type so the first thing that I have to
cope is how to modify this so I picked
immediate solution just use two function
one will return to forth there is
intersection or intersection and if I
have true answer then just just compute
the intersection so I made I created the
wrapper function okay let's get a
symbolic expression the reason is is
there was a bunch of code I didn't want
to modify too much so just change the
name of the function and function and
then this wrapper function called to two
other functions that are compiled so it
should be very quick okay so the first
one is a boolean function true/false you
have intersection okay and I compile it
to see which is the fastest option
before version 11.10 tulips did this
project with and this repeats part of
the computation actually I can modify
this just once will effect or vomit as
it were computed with previous function
and even short the computation time now
if I repeated 10,000 times with the same
now I have a set of two triangles per
wall which is highly efficient I don't
have small angles and actually I got a
photo because comparing to the first
version of only mathematical about 37
okay this is very good and there is this
result up from the laptop I got better
results on the desktop okay now now I
want to do it better
okay so whether it's means that I use
parallel computation of mathematical
just one things
parallel parallel I got even better
results okay so the best that I can get
with this computer is about photo 60
here on the small laptop it's Foucault's
okay on my desktop computer is it goes
and zoom so it's better and doesn't hit
it can compute for a long time and it's
okay so just some results to see I took
a random sample of weighs like 150 Ray's
just presentation out of several tens of
thousands of phrase just associate evoke
this is like the direct hit now a single
reflection a double reflection a triple
of flexion I have another image for the
reflection but here and now version
follows what a plan is to do GPU but all
my computers are Apple and Apple decided
abandon OpenGL and I cannot use CUDA so
reading the problem so I stopped the
project for for the time now until
somebody will decide what Mathematica
should do with AMD GPUs okay if not
somebody else will continue to develop
it on Windows and Linux okay final
comment I found the page in world from
dot-com actually describing some of the
internals and on this internal see
describe what happened with graphics
okay
and actually to do graphics with a with
Mathematica you have all the
functionality of ray tracing okay so I
hope somebody will pick up the ethics
glove and provide us some interface that
we can use as external users to do right
pressing using this functionality and
let us modify it okay this is the last
minute comment what I have seen in this
count
with version 12 with all the new
compiler capabilities actually I can do
much better than here so and waiting and
it was the next version so okay thank
you
[Applause]